لكن ما هي الذخائر دقيقه التوجيه التي
ستزيد روسيا من انتاجها تعرف بانها سلاح
يدمر هدفا ما بدقه مع تقليل الاضرار
الجانبيه الناجمه عن هذا التدمير وتشمل
الذخائر الصواريخ الباليستيه وقذائف
المدفعيه وغيرها هذه الذخائر مزوده بنظام
تحديد المواقع العالمي جي بي اس او
التوجيه بالليزر او انظمه الملاحه بالقصور
الذاتي لتحسين دقه السلاح وتقليل هامش
الخطا الى اقل من ثلاثه امتار توجه
الذخائر نحو اهداف ثابته ومتحركه
محدوده او كبيره وسواء كانت على الارض او
في البحر او في الجو وهي تستخدم كسلاح
مضاد لطائرات او السفن وغيرها على سبيل
المثال تستخدم روسيا صواريخ كينجال في حرب
اوكرانيا ويتميز بان ان انحرافه عن الهدج
الهدف لا يتجاوز
مترا واحدا اضافه الى صواريخ اسكندر ام
وصواريخ سيركون وغيرها